somebody please get this to ben simmons
before the game or during halftime now i
want you know ben
i'm not here to ridicule i'm here to
help
you've been having some trouble with the
free throws hey man
i have people are are putting pressure
on you and in the grand scheme of things
i'm aware that your free throw shooting
ability has
no consequence on the quality
of my day-to-day life and that sports is
just a distraction i should be doing
something else right now i had so much
you you know you made 30 million man and
that's about
40 million australians so it's just
it's just part of the game so so my
proposal to you today
switch it up you got to go under here
man go underhand
it's just i know you don't want to do it
is go
underhand go underhead and i know you're
probably thinking
uh why why would i listen to the
hannibal birds about it because all
right
i've lived it i've lived it look
wow man
look at that you hit a crowd they don't
care
do it man do it underhand you're gonna
be in atlanta it's gonna be so loud
quavo is gonna be there people gonna be
doing this to distract you
just switch it up because guess what
even if it doesn't work
people will respect you for making a
drastic change
under pressure you're showing
flexibility showing quick thought go
underhand man
do it man you could do this listen dog
look at i was hanging looking i was
hanging out with
another he looked like you sort of a
little bit
and look at that i shot underhand and
jeans
got the bounce and we shook hands you
can do this dog
do it ben insanity
is doing the same thing over and over
and expecting different results
go underhand today for
we all want to die one day you know